J'avais déjà vu Benedict à la
télévision britannique et je l'ai vraiment
recherché. C'était l'un de ces moments magiques.
J'ai eu ce cool d'aller dans une pièce et de lire
le scénario. Il est juste sorti
immédiatement de la page. C'est un
scénario tellement puissant et  J'ai pensé que c'est une
partie merveilleuse c'est une partie vraiment
merveilleuse le premier point d'appel
était d'essayer de devenir un assez bon
cavalier pour faire ce qui était requis dans le
film en
raison d'un doute de bouteille Stewart est le
soldat le disciplinaire et je pense
Waverly  a une sorte de
respect pour lui et une sensibilité, mais
je pense que Nichols a une idée de l'horreur de
la guerre avec l'Allemagne dans le nord de la
France et je pense que sa façon de
faire face à sa propre peur est qu'il
dessine ces belles  des croquis de Joey
et ne jouant pas seulement un soldat je
joue un soldat qui a aussi un
esprit artistique à
droite alors voyons de quoi vous
êtes faits deux jokers allons-nous c'est à quoi
ressemble une confiance tranquille j'attendrai l'équipe t  o
au duc d'york